[Musique]
moi
c'était le développement bienvenu parce que
cela nous a rendu tellement de choses faciles
[Applaudissements]
pris dans les lacunes d'essayer d'évaluer
le bureau parfois
afin que vous puissiez faire tout cela dans le
confort de votre
[Musique  ]
house
[Music]
ce que la pandémie a fait, c'est que les gens
apprécient que ces choses peuvent être
faites
je ne vois pas non plus pourquoi je devrais me rendre au
bureau du prêtre
et voir pendant deux heures je suis une personne occupée
je ne le fais pas  je veux y aller et il y a
beaucoup de monde et puis
j'attends j'attends j'attends
je veux savoir que c'est mon heure je
peux
venir voir le prêtre et ensuite continuer
avec ce que je suis  ça
va donc ce n'est pas une application pour la pandémie
c'est une application pour l'efficacité
[Musique]
donc
vous